okay the Speaker of the House of Commons
made this announcement in the house
I wish to say something about the
announcement which has just been made
about her majesty
I know I speak on behalf of the entire
house when I said that we send our best
wishes to a Magister the queen and that
she and the royal family are in our
thoughts and prayers at this moment I'm
going to take no more just to if there
is anything else we will update the
house accordingly thank you in Blackford
[Music]
and in response to the Prime Minister
Liz truss told the house that the whole
country will be deeply concerned by the
news from Buckingham Palace this lunch
time adding that her thoughts and the
thoughts of the people across the United
Kingdom are with her majesty the queen
and her family at this time so a lot of
well warm wishes being sent to the royal
family let's return to our role
correspondent Rhiannon Mills Rhiannon I
mean obviously people will be concerned
about the queen we last saw her on
Tuesday didn't didn't we when she met
the new prime minister and she is 96 and
does look rather frail but but what else
are you able to tell us so Jane I have
literally just heard in in the last few
moments
um that their raw highnesses the Prince
of Wales and The Duchess of Cornwall
have traveled to Balmoral and also that
the Duke of Cambridge is traveling to
Balmoral as well we know that Prince
Charles Camilla who have been spending a
great tight deal of time in Scotland
over the summer holidays they often do
they have their own property at Burke
Hall which is just up the road from
Balmoral and also some of the papers
have been suggesting that the Prince of
Wales has been slightly unusually making
daily visits to go and see the queen
um whether that's accurate or not but
just to give you an idea of some of the
the topics that people have been talking
about when it comes to the queen being
being up in Scotland but yeah it has to
be it said it is unusual to hear that
the Duke of Cambridge is also now
traveling up to Balmoral but I think it
does very much chime with that statement
that we had from Buckingham Palace just
after half past 12 in which they said
that following further evaluation this
morning the Queen's doctors are
concerned for Her Majesty's health and
have recommended that she remains under
medical supervision the queen remains
comfortable and is a Balmoral they also
Einstein and have informed family
members which of course would would make
sense now that we hear that they are
they are all heading um on their way to
many of them are heading on their way to
Balmoral at the moment to No Doubt
um see the queen for themselves um there
had been some speculation around that
the queen may have fallen but we're
being guided away from that has to be
said that a lot of speculation started
certainly on social media when pieces of
paper were being passed around it seemed
within the house Commons
um shortly after that energy statement
that was made by prime minister Liz
truss so that's where speculation
started
um has to be said it's really unusual
for the palace to give us updates when
it comes to to the Queen's Medical
matters we know that obviously last
night they had to do the same they had
to tell us that she had to cancel that
privy council meeting which she was
going to do virtually from Balmoral and
then today we're being told that
um not just that the queen is being told
to rest but the doctors they are
concerned about her and she remains
under medical supervision but also worth
pointing out she hasn't been moved to
hospital she is currently still at
Balmoral which of course is where we've
seen the latest pictures of her
um I have to say there were many people
who looked at that picture of her
standing in front of the fireplace
in the drawing room waiting to welcome
her her 15th prime minister and she was
it was more of an image of a grandmother
I would say than as head of state right
and in some ways I think people did look
at her and think gosh she has she has
become more frail and and certainly I
think we have
seen that uh over the last 12 months I
was thinking back to to this time last
year where we saw the queen planting a
tree at Balmoral with the Prince of
Wales she was then very busy she opened
the Scottish Parliament she opened the
Welsh Parliament she was outside
Buckingham Palace launching the
Commonwealth bat on relay with Prince
Edward she she also then conducted a
business Summit at Windsor and she was
incredibly busy but then in October she
was told to cancel at the last minute a
trip to Northern Ireland and it was then
around that time that we we heard that
she had had to go into hospital for some
tests
everything that I've been hearing over
the last few weeks there's been no sense